tensions mount on the al-aqsa mosque
compound in occupied east jerusalem
dozens of palestinians are injured in
confrontations with israeli police
could the violence escalate and how
should israeli and palestinian leaders
respond
this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
muhammad jim joom the al-aqsa mosque
compound is holy to muslims jews and
christians with ramadan passover and
easter taking place at the same time
this year tensions are running
particularly high in occupied east
jerusalem
on sunday israeli police forcibly
dispersed palestinian worshipers who set
up barricades to prevent ultra
right-wing jewish groups from entering
palestinians see such visits as
provocations some were arrested
paramedics say they were blocked from
helping the injured
jews are forbidden from praying or
performing rituals at the compound but
ultranationalist groups want to change
this
natasha name explains from occupied east
jerusalem
well the 545 jewish visitors who came to
the al-aqsa compound during their
designated three-hour visit
today have left the compound as has the
israeli police but earlier 20 people
were injured five of them were taken to
the hospital and a total of 18 people
according to the israeli police have
been arrested four of them for
vandalizing the buses carrying the
jewish visitors
the israeli police say that early this
morning they went inside the compound
because palestinian rioters were
amassing rocks and stones and creating
or attempting to create barricades that
were would have prevented the jewish
visitors from accessing the compound
through the designated gate the israelis
actually have a key and do restrict
access
to that specific gate but the police
stress at no time during this tense
period were muslims not allowed to
continue worshiping a note about the
people who were inside we saw men women
boys and girls these are jews who are
settlers who are members of
ultranationalist and zionist
groups they believe that they have the
right to pray
on the site the temple mount a holy site
for jews is also within the al-aqsa
compound and in recent years this group
once on the fringes has been growing in
numbers has become more vocal and has
even gained the backing of several
israeli politicians but for now again
they are only allowed to go inside the
compound and wander around they are not
allowed to pray some of the most
volatile periods in the
israeli-palestinian conflict have
centered around the man-made hill in
occupied east jerusalem's old city
muslims call it the haram sharif or the
noble sanctuary because it contains two
of islam's holiest places the al-aqsa
mosque and the dome of the rock jews
call the hill the temple mount and
revere the area at its base known as the
western wall
with so many important religious sites
in a small space the situation around
the hill is often tense any change to
the status quo or a threat to one of the
holy sites can quickly lead to unrest
last year violence in the compound
triggered missile attacks from gaza into
israel followed by 11 days of israeli
bombardment on the gaza strip that
killed hundreds of people the al-aqsa
tensions add to rising violence between
palestinians and israelis since march 22
palestinian attacks in israeli cities
have killed at least 14 people
israeli forces responded with more raids
shootings and arrests in the occupied
west bank
at least 16 palestinians have died
all right let's bring in our guests in
occupied east jerusalem ziad abu zayad
lawyer and political analyst
in ra anana in israel nimrod novik
former senior policy adviser to former
israeli prime minister shimon peres
and in doha amrazem professor of middle
east history and anthropology at shawnee
state university a warm welcome to you
all and thanks so much for joining us
today on inside story ziad let me start
with you today
how far
might we see the violence escalate
well i think it depends on the israeli
government and israeli governor the
current israeli government is uh taken
hostage by the right wing and they are
trying to change the status quo on haram
sharif and allowing the jewish
fanatics to go to the courtyards of the
mosque and yesterday on friday there was
a violent attack even inside the built
mosque
so if the israeli government continue uh
these actions i'm afraid that it will
not stop by where it is now but things
will escalate to more violence and uh
this is something which all of us should
not seek i should not try to get to
nimrod are you concerned that this is
going to get worse
yes of course i mean i lived through
previous
moments of tension that
escalated and got out of control just a
year ago
we all experienced 11 days of terrible
violence
uh so yes i'm afraid that the extremists
on both sides
are feeding on each other
um and that even a government that i
think has been
conducted conducting itself uh quite
carefully and learned lessons from
previous
occasions uh even that might not be
enough
i'm i just want to take a step back um
why are things so contentious when it
comes to the al-aqsa mosque compound why
are why are tensions often so high there
could you just walk our viewers through
that a bit
i i think yes of course um but i think
it's important to understand it's not
just the the temple man it's it's the
the whole concept of the city itself the
city of jerusalem and it's always been
politicized from the moment it was
founded essentially by david david chose
that side simply because it happened to
be convenient politically convenient to
alam to unite the northern tribes of the
southern tribes if you move up to um the
you know
the time of islam and uh you know the
after the conquest obviously abdul malik
uh thought that this would be a good way
for him to
uh use the the the location use this
side to build the dome of the rock and
to build the obviously um
that very important sort of monument
there as a means to counter his own
troubles with al-zubair who
was in rebellion against him and had
shut him out of mecca and then if we
move to the more modern period and we
consider how the zionist movement
themselves viewed jerusalem originally
they were very indifferent to it they
were not
uh that attached it they did not see it
as essential to the foundation of their
state and in fact many of its most
important founders
for example heard herzel would write
that he was shocked by the filth and ben
gurion didn't visit it for the first
three years and
for the most part
it is often uh you know the city and
obviously it's most important
centered around
the uh temple mount
for the uh
for the obviously for those of the
jewish faith and and for muslims it's
the dome of the rock and and the al-aqsa
mosque it's always been politicized and
it comes in to play every time
uh there is um
you know some conflict or issue over the
politics of the place
nimrod from your perspective how should
israeli and palestinian leaders respond
to all of this
look um this is probably the the hottest
spot on earth
the convergence of the three
monotheistic religions
and you know regardless of factual basis
in history
i wouldn't dare challenge
the face of others and will not accept
others challenging my faith so we have
three uh
of the leading religious in the world
considering this as their one of their
most uh precious
uh uh places on the globe um
and when we have a moment when the three
religions also have three holidays
converge
uh you really have the makings
of uh
an explosive situation
as long as there is no political
solution that defines
um what is what and whose is whose
and we have failed in accomplishing that
over the past decades
i hope that the next generation of
leadership would be wiser than all of us
but at the moment
i think that all leaders all over the
place
should call for calm
and should
point out
lash at
and deal
fiercely
with extremists
who are trying to ignite the situation
uh given their own
exclusive approach
to what should be shared
ziad from your perspective is there a
constructive way that israeli and
palestinian leaders can respond
well of course of course i i must say
that since
the year 2002
there was a systematic israeli policy
which gradually started
trying to change the situation in the
haram
and to allow jews to come to the
courtyards of the haram sharif and then
later later in the recent years they
were allowing them to pray and to have
religious
ceremonies
this policy is actually like playing
with with the time bomb i don't agree
with with nimrod that it is extremists
on both sides uh on our side it's a
popular reaction they are touching on a
very sensitive nerve which is a haram
sharif so the people who were reacting
on friday in the recent days and recent
weeks they were not fanatics they were
not extremists they were the average
palestinians who are against
trying to convert the mosques to become
a synagogue or to divide the mosque as
they did in in
moscow
ibrahim
in hebron
you ask what the leaders can do i think
the leaders can
should respect the status quo which was
agreed upon since the year 1854-55
during their ottoman
rule
and each religion has control over its
sights uh when it comes to the willing
world and there is a rule
by by the court that the israelis do not
have control
over over the wall itself but can you
pray in front of the world what happened
in 1967 when israel occupied east
jerusalem they demolished the whole
quarter which is called abu muarta's
moroccan
neighborhood it was demolished and it
was turned to explain that in front of
the wailing world so we in camp david
talks we agreed that the jews will have
control over the wedding wall and the
area in front of the wedding wall and
they can practice
the religious sermon is there and the
muslims will have control over
what's happening now is that they are
trying to take part of alhara machete i
think it's it's it's naive and stupid to
think that they can change this
situation they can take part of inside
the haram sharif they can pray and say
haram sharif and the muslims will sit
quiet and welcome these changes the
leaders must try to avoid any friction
between muslims and jews and should
avoid converting this conflict from a
national conflict between palestinians
under occupation and israeli occupation
the conflict between religious fanatics
we should avoid that and we should not
lead that until now it's it is contained
it is a national conflict it is a
political conflict but
there is a change a a massive change
within the israeli society that they are
shifting towards the right wing towards
the extremists and this is now yeah i
see it and there it is
parliamentary i'm sorry you can see it
also in the government i'm sorry to
interrupt you i do want to get back to a
point you were making in just a moment
but i i want to ask ahmed about the fact
that
ramadan passover and easter are all
converging this year
how much more volatile does that make
this situation
well obviously extremely volatile i mean
when you have three very very important
religious
holidays ceremonies
events all at the same time and you have
that in a highly politicized
um situation
you know because the
not only is is the
are the religious
let's say that the location is highly
politicized but you also have extreme
it is tensions associated with
uh these uh religious sort of uh
ceremonies as well and um
the convergence is almost inevitably
going to
produce the kind of scenes that we've
been watching on our tv um the last few
days and it's it's very important that
and again i repeat i think
the politicization
of
the uh religious dimension
to this to to the location to the side
is what is making it so difficult
you know jews and and muslims and
christians have managed to
share and and live side by side for many
centuries in different periods so when
they don't it is generally due to a
reason that is associated with
politicization rather than the fact that
somehow as humans were incapable of uh
sharing
um nimrod the this violence that we're
seeing at the al-aqsa mosque compound as
well as the recent spate of attacks in
israel
how much of a challenge has that been
for this very fragile coalition
of prime minister bennett's government
how big of a challenge is it for the
prime minister
look just like uh on the ground um when
extreme elements uh
seize the moment and try to
ignite
the situation the same happens in
politics
um and the opposition of course
on the right
uh is all over the prime minister the
ministry of defense and the incumbent
government
that they are not tough enough
on palestinian challenge for jewish
rights
where is the government and here i take
issue with
with my colleagues
where the government was was doing
everything it could and i think uh
quite well with some exceptions that
that i uh take issue with but overall
the strategy was was i think uh meant to
bring a calm and to restore the status
quo that has been infringed upon in the
previous administration here in israel
over the past three four years
the status quo which basically says
that on haram sharif temple mount
muslims pray
others visit
uh and there were jewish extremists who
were not willing to accept that they
cannot pray where uh where muslims can
and they are still trying to do so and
anyone who echoes their voices that
tomorrow morning they're going to
establish a synagogue or other nonsense
that tomorrow morning they will do
sacrifices of lambs
on temple mount it will never happen
but those who echo their threats
and their intents
are intensifying the tension
between the communities as to uh
political consequences
um obviously we have a new coalition
here about a year old
that has for the first time ever
and our party and an islamic one atlanta
they are under tremendous pressure and
not to stay in the coalition
uh because the government
again is being accused uh of being tough
on muslims and not on jews which i think
is not the case
uh will they withdraw that pressure uh
and we will see another day when this a
quite interesting and refreshing
coalition will continue to function i
have no idea ziad um how big does the
disconnect remain between palestinian
leadership and palestinians and just how
frustrated are palestinians right now
with palestinian leadership
well i i must be frank with you i don't
think that the palestinian leadership
has any control over what is happening
inside the old city of jerusalem and
what's happening inside the core the
most and not any other political uh
movement not hamas he had not anyone
else it is it is our spanish spontaneous
reaction of the the people
now uh
if we want
to change this situation we can we can
say let's go back to how we were living
together jews muslims and christians and
there were no afflictions there were no
problems but as i said earlier they are
trying to change the situation there was
a time when there was a
court verdict saying that jews can go to
the most
but
the police will decide if they can go or
not depending on the public order and
all the time every time the police said
okay if we allow the jews to go to the
mosque there will be disturbing the
the public order and the public security
so we will not let them to go to the
mosque
and this was okay we they were not
coming to the mosque and there were no
troubles now we see the police escorting
them and we see the police trying to
evacuate the mosque from the muslim
prayers in order to bring the israelis
to pray inside that they are so the most
which are from an islamic point of view
they are part of the mosque because from
our point of view the mock the mosque is
not only the belt area but it's all the
core the the uh
quality arts which we call them
and
around the most all these are one
compound one of these are them was
if if the israeli government would stop
these fanatics and and look our problem
is not with the jewish religion i was
talking recently with the rabbi from
yadutta torah and he said to me i'm
against going to the mosque
my religion tells me that i'm not
allowed to put my fingers between the
stones of the wedding world from the
outside of the mosque
this is until it was for centuries there
was a jewish halacha not allowing jews
to go to the most
now they're these zionists they're
fanatics they are nationalists they are
not religious
they claim on them themselves as
seculars they are trying to achieve a
national goal from going to the most it
is not it's not religion in this case
and we should not allow these fanatics
bing veer and smoot rich and all this
guy we should not allow them to dictate
the future of the relations between us
and their israelis there is a very
fragile situation we should try to avoid
any clashes to to avoid any any
bloodshed and try to seek ways how we
can find a breakthrough towards the
solution which make us live together
side by side this government is not the
government that can do it and and
unfortunately we see that the right wing
is all the time having more
governments and more power
and we are they're bringing us to an
area where we don't want to be there
um jews are forbidden from praying or
performing rituals at the compound but
there are ultra nationalist groups that
want to change this why
i mean obviously as as you heard um this
has
everything to do with
the
um effort to attempt to follow you know
push a
uh ultra nationalist um exclusivist
agenda by uh certain uh
you know members of israelis or israeli
groups and they
use an extreme perhaps or or
a more fundamentalist
interpretation of their own sort of
practices to say i can you know by by
praying here i've somehow laid claim to
something and i i think that's
why they're doing it now um
obviously there are going to be divided
views amongst
the jewish community as to how to
address this they were um you know we
know that for example uh the the whole
issue
you know of religious devotion
uh to the city was not regarded as
involving any duty
was not connected to regaining
sovereignty over it this was something
that was developed later as part of a
political
ideology and not as part of necessarily
a
religious doctrinal one and it's
important to separate these two the the
doctrinal side from the political
ideology side and i think that's what's
missing here and i'm we only have about
a minute left but let me just ask you
are there certain concrete steps that
could be taken immediately that could
that could calm the overall situation
i think
you know
certainly obviously separating
the parties would be a good start by
respecting those boundaries um you know
there there is an appropriate place for
um
you know jews to go and pray during
their their holy uh period and just as
is there is a
uh you know a religious place for the
muslims to go and pray in their in a
holy uh
period as well
and ensuring that this separation is
maintained
and then try to build some sort of
confidence building measures you know
try to
tell both sides that hey look these are
the boundaries and it's important for
the for the civil peace that we maintain
these boundaries and neither side feels
that somehow its rights are are being
attacked or or
are under threat and in this case
unfortunately the threat is coming from
the jewish israeli side um and not the
other way around
um and and i think these would be very
constructive ways that the current
israeli government could follow if it
wish to sort of ensure that this these
kinds of events are not repeated whether
they can given the political fragility
of the coalitions that we see is another
matter
all right well we have run out of time
so we're going to have to leave the
conversation there thanks so much to all
of our guests ziad abu zayad nimrod
novik and amri lazem
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website aljazeera.com and
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story for me
muhammad jim jim in the whole team here
in doha bye for now
[Music]